bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo nous
sommes à bruxelles au coeur du parlement
européen et l'actualité de la semaine ce
sont les paradis fiscaux l'europe en
compte une demi douzaine en son sein
comment lutter contre l'évasion fiscale
c'est ce que tente de faire les
responsables européens l'événement c'est
aussi le décès de margaret thatcher
l'ancien premier ministre britannique a
marqué l'histoire européenne florilège
des télévisions d'europe
la vérité c'est que margaret thatcher
n'a pas seulement dirigé notre pays elle
l'a sauvée et elle restera comme le plus
grand premier ministre de l'histoire
moderne de la grande bretagne
j'ai été profondément attristé
d'entendre les nouvelles de la mort de
la baronne thatcher
elle était sans aucun doute une grande
femme d'état la première femme premier
ministre dans son pays est une actrice
circonspecte mais engagée dans l'union
européenne
le président de la commission monsieur
de l'or a dit l'autre jour qu'il voulait
que le parlement européen soit le corps
démocratique de la communauté que la
commission soit l'exécutif et que le
conseil des ministres soit le sénat nous
sur le plan européen la dame de fer
qu'on soit l'europe comme un outil pour
accélérer le libre échange et garantir
la concurrence elle refuse toute idée de
super état européen et exige de la cee
d'alors le célèbre chèque d'un milliard
de livres sterling pour la contribution
britannique
elle obtiendra sa restitution en 1984 il
n'y a pas de demi-mesure lorsque l'on
parle de marianne thatcher elle était la
plus aimée mais aussi la plus détestée
la femme la plus influente du pays
cholet est la plus caricaturer aussi je
voudrais insister quelques hui sont crus
cette semaine nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir content dickinson bonjour
bonjour vous êtes chef du bureau
européen à bruxelles de radio france
vous êtes le grand spécialiste des
questions européennes vous connaissez
tous des arcanes de la politique
européenne
alors les sisters et est connu en europe
pour son nom son intransigeance son
opposition dans les débats européens
notamment sur le budget européen avec ce
rabais britannique qu'elle a contribué à
obtenir pour son pays de haute lutte
quelques l image qu est ce qu elle
incarnait pour vous eh bien les milieux
européens dont je fais par la banque
partie retiennent de madame thatcher
l'image une personne intransigeante
agaçante horripilante très souvent
quelqu'un qui était extrêmement sûre
d'elle-même qui intervenait à tout bout
de champ qui poussait à bout ses
adversaires ses partenaires et qui au
fond n'a jamais eu beaucoup de
considération pour ceux ci elle pensait
qu'elle était investi d'un pouvoir
absolu qu'elle représentait à elle-même
toute la force toutes les vertus tous
les intérêts des peuples du royaume uni
et de ce point de vue là et l'obtenait
le plus souvent gain de cause
elle poussait les gens dans leurs
retranchements et les avait à l'usure et
pourtant et pourtant face d'elle il
avait des adversaires ou des partenaires
selon qu'ils étaient de poids excusez du
peu pour la france giscard pour
l'allemagne elle mouche ruth et pourtant
ces deux là il les a roulés
dans la farine et les reparti vous lui
disiez avec son rabais sur la
contribution britannique au budget
communautaire un rabais qui déjà à
l'époque ne se justifiaient toute façon
comptable pas vraiment et aujourd'hui il
est britannique et c'est de faire croire
que c'est un mec qui perpétuelle ce ne
doit pas l'être
est-ce qu'elle était fondamentalement
européenne est ce qu elle a quand même
apporté quelque chose
un construction européenne va et leur
apporter ce qu'il souhaitait en retirer
en réalité pour les britanniques du
temps de madame thatcher est encore dans
une grande mesure aujourd'hui l'union
européenne la construction européenne
c'est très secondaire
c'est un marché un supermarché où vient
faire ses emplettes on pense qu'on veut
et on laisse le reste donc madame
thatcher a effectivement contribué
madame thatcher voulait ce grand marché
européen qui existe aujourd'hui
qu'ils soient parfaits encore de nos
jours et pour ce faire c'est avec
enthousiasme qu'elle a apposé sa
signature au bas de l'acte unique
européen pourtant voulue par le
socialiste français jacques delors qui
présidait la commission à l'époque dont
il s'agissait de bénéficier d'un marché
vers lequel les produits britanniques
pouvaient s'exporter de même madame
thatcher a toujours beaucoup soutenu
l'idée de l'élargissement de l'union
européenne au plus grand nombre possible
de pays membres pourquoi parce qu'elle
savait très bien que l'élargissement
c'était quelque chose qui freina qui tua
éventuellement l'approfondissement et
donc la partie politique de la
construction européenne et la rejeter
entièrement
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les choses ont
vraiment changé par la grande bretagne
est ce que la politique menée
actuellement par le conservateur cameron
est différente est fondamentalement
différente de celle de marianne thatcher
en 1979 quand il était entré au 10
downing street madame thatcher et tient
la tête d'un pays qui étaient en grand
déclin économique et désemparé du point
de vue social
elle a fait quelque chose et la rebâtir
une nation l'expédition malouines n'est
pas pour rien dans le regain de fierté
nationale des britanniques
mais aujourd'hui la grande bretagne et
sur un déclin nouveau pétrole et le gaz
de la mer du nord ne sont pas éternels
il y a des schismes intérieur il ya ce
fameux référendum sur l'indépendance
écossaise donc l'horizon est couvert de
brouillard une fois de plus au royaume
uni et ce royaume uni là effectivement
se pose aujourd'hui des questions avec à
sa tête quelqu'un qui n'est pas
l'héritier véritablement de margaret
thatcher markets and share avec cette
intelligence de la situation dans une
négociation de faire en sorte qu'elle
laissait toujours planer une espèce de
menaces très vague mais jamais ils ne se
seraient permises c'était une faiblesse
effectivement de dire c'est ça où nous
quittons l'union européenne jamais elle
ne l'a dit et c'est le piège dans lequel
david cameron son successeur s'est
enfermé alors elle est aussi connue pour
ses phrases son ton péremptoire certains
actions notamment celui ci des riches
noceurs native
il n'y a pas d'alternative c'est valable
aussi notamment pour la politique
économique qu'elle a menée mais
aujourd'hui on a l'impression d'entendre
aussi ce discours canton quand on entend
certains dirigeants européens justifier
la nécessité de mener des politiques de
rigueur
est ce que ce n'est pas ce discours là
aussi qui domine aujourd'hui le il n'y a
pas d'alternative
cette sorte de pensée unique économique
c'est la même partition mais je n'ai pas
le même interprète les interprètes
actuels n'ont pas le talent de madame
thatcher et bien merci
ce sera le mot de la fin et on va parler
à présent merci quentin dickinson on va
parler à présent de la situation
politique en italie
très compliqué puisque le pays n'a
toujours pas de gouvernement
on en parle avec un journaliste italien
lorenzo consoli vais d'abord cette
question l'italie est-elle ingouvernable
25 février la gauche de pier luigi
bersani arrive en tête des élections
générales italienne devant le parti de
silvio berlusconi
le leader démocrate obtient la majorité
à la chambre des députés mais pas au
sénat en raison de règles électorales
complexes et c'est un nouveau venu le
mouvement cinq étoiles de l'ancien
comique beppe grillo qui créait la
surprise de ce scrutin
arrivé à la troisième place
l'information se définit par son rejet
du système politique et des partis
traditionnels
problème les trois forces politiques
sont incapables de se mettre d'accord
pour former un gouvernement silvio
berlusconi refuse de faire alliance avec
les centristes de mario monti dont la
coalition fait moins de 10%
bp drion refuse de négocier avec les
autres formations
résultat un mois plus tard pier luigi
bersani jette l'épongé
à ce stade tout simplement le président
de la république a décidé de conduire
directement ses propres consultations
c'est pour débloquer la situation le
président de la république giorgio
napolitano a une idée il charge un
groupe d'experts de trouver une solution
à cette crise composé de personnalités
de tous bords ce collège a une double
mission réformer la loi électorale
à l'origine de l'impasse et proposer des
mesures pour faire repartir l'économie
italienne en récession depuis un an et
demi
six semaines après les élections
législatives le pays n'a toujours pas de
gouvernement
alors l'italie est-elle ingouvernable
alors pour tenter de comprendre cette
situation très compliquée un journaliste
italien est avec nous lorenzo consoli
bonjour alors vous écrivait notamment
pour l' agence de presse italienne
teignouse et vous êtes un grand
spécialiste des questions européennes
expliquez-nous ce qui se passe en fait
est ce que votre pays aujourd'hui est
ingouvernable et quelle est l'issue non
je ne crois pas que l'italie soit sont
ingouvernables le problème est que on
s'est retrouvé avec une loi électorale
qui était fait pour ne pas permettre au
parti qui a gagné les élections le parti
démocrate de centre gauche de pouvoir
gouverner puisque même si la majorité
dont la chambre des députés
le système électoral électorale est
telle que dans le sénat le parti n'a pas
de la majorité et donc comme le système
et daniel parfaitement bicaméral c'est à
dire que les lois doivent passer à la
chambre et au sénat
comme le titre on ne peut pas gouverner
sans orale en réalité dans ses nerfs
aussi en clair pour bien vous comprendre
c'est aussi là c'est la loi électorale
qui est en partie responsable de cette
impasse mais ce qui est pas aussi une
responsabilité des chefs des différents
chefs de marty qui visiblement ne vivent
pas sur la loi électorale a été fait par
le gouvernement berlusconi
et avec surtout l'alliance et la ligue
du nord qui qui a qui avait vraiment
conçu la loi électorale pourquoi être
favori alors nourrir en fait un bisou il
surtout surtout là où elle a sa base
électorale dans le nord ça lui permet
d'avoir une emprise sur le sénat en fait
mais c'est vrai que les parties et
italiens n'ont pas changé la loi quand
il avait la possibilité de le faire
avant les élections et c'est vrai aussi
que
il y à cette protestation des gens les
gens sont c'est pour ça qu'ils ont voté
pour le moment de glee l'eau contre la
politique la mauvaise politique le fait
que les gens sont innombrables ils sont
les politiciens se sont le plus payé
d'europe et donc là il est un polémique
très force pour baisser les salaires des
le coût de la politique et les salaires
des politiciens et donc il y a aussi
certainement là qui est très important
ça a provoqué une situation dans
laquelle on est passé d'une situation
bipolaire bipolaire donc emporté
entrevoir a pas de centre gauche avec un
petit centre en citations tripolaire
trois pôles qui correspond plus ou moins
à 30% de l'électorat chacun plus un
petit centre qui écrira qui est resté
tout y est ce que est ce que les forces
de tt green aux sons sont importantes
dans le pays
ce qu'il faut compter avec ce troisième
homme alors une force de beppe grillo
ont été en surprises personne ne
s'attendait qu'ils arrivent à la définir
presque le première partie ils ne sont
pas les premières parties dans la
chambre des députés
parce que le vote des électeurs à
l'étranger a été majoritairement pour le
parti démocratique donc le premier parti
si on compte les bourdelle étrangères
c'est le parti démocrate mais si on ne
compte pas aller voir de l'étrangère ce
et dp ville est arrivée première dans la
chambre alors lui le problème c'est que
lui et son mouvement ne veulent pas
faire des alliances avec les autres
partis des partis traditionnels ça va se
débloquer prochainement vous pensez
alors la stratégie de bersani guéret
chargé de former le gouvernement et qui
pour l'instant est gelé parce que on est
en situation très difficile de le
président de la république ne peut pas
dissoudre les le parlement il faut élire
le nouveau président de la république
avant de pouvoir former un gouvernement
aujourd'hui est la stratégie de bayssan
est très simple il dit moi je ne peux
pas faire une alliance avec berlusconi
parce que mon électorat ne
comprendraient pas et ça ne
fonctionnerait pas de toute façon parce
que les choses que le centre gauche veut
le centre droite ne veut pas donc ça
c'est première chose deuxième chose on
va essayer avec bp de limur si bp grillo
ne veut pas l'alliance avec nous on ira
aux prochaines élections et là on va
regagner le voit qu'on a perdus nous le
centre gauche alors que beppe grillo va
perdre recevoir parce qu'il n'a pas
permis il n'aura pas permis de faire le
gouvernement
eh bien merci pour cet éclairage on
suivra cette situation merci beaucoup
alors l'europe peut-elle lutter contre
les paradis fiscaux c'est l'autre
question à la une cette semaine françois
beaudonnet en parle dans un instant avec
son invité mais d'abord direction
nicosie à chypre où la crise économique
succède à la crise bancaire reportage de
jérémie hoffmann et d'orge a beaucoup
des banquiers dans la rue
la scène aurait de quoi surprendre un
français elle a pourtant bien eu lieu en
plein centre ville de nicosie ici
jusqu'à maintenant les banques étaient
toutes puissantes
elles sont désormais dans le collimateur
de l'europe leurs syndicats crient à
l'injustice
nous ne demandons pas de faveurs
particulières on ne fait pas la manche
on demande juste à récupérer nos
économies ce jour là ils sont plusieurs
milliers de manifestants à battre le
pavé en direction du parlement
énorme mobilisation pour ce petit pays
d'à peine 1 million d'habitants
et parmi ces banquiers en colère andré
inscrit sa fille ces bacs pour le droit
pour nos emplois pour nos pensions de
retraites et pensions
ils veulent nous mais supprimée et l'une
de ses victimes anonymes du plan de
sauvetage imposées par l'europe
il dirige un service informatique de la
banque like i deuxième banque du pays
qui doit être démantelé dans les
prochaines semaines trente ans de
carrière qui s'effondre et la
perspective d'une retraite dorée qui
s'éloigne on va se retrouver sans
pension sans nourriture imaginez si vous
aviez 65 ou 70 ans vous retrouver sans
argent
comment faire eh bien vous finissez à la
soupe populaire une angoisse partagée
avec sa femme ksenia elle aussi fait
partie du cortège elle aussi travail
pour l'aïe qui chez les crises à fils
toute la famille est touchée
ça va être très compliqué pour nos
enfants
il va falloir qu'il travaille pour
financer leurs études cette crise est
synonyme d'éclatement de la famille
pourquoi nos enfants aurait qu'une envie
de revenir
ils n'ont plus d'avenir ici il faut bien
comprendre que c'est toute l'institution
familiale très importante ici qui va
disparaître cette colère du peuple
les parlementaires chypriote l'entendent
et la comprennent mais la nouvelle
majorité au pouvoir n'a pas vraiment eu
le choix en acceptant le plan de
sauvetage proposé par l'union européenne
nour est qu'on ne sont que 7 imed les 10
milliards qui vont être accordée à la
république de chypre et en même temps
nous espérons qu'il y ait quelque chose
va ça va changer au niveau de la
gouvernance économique de les rejoindre
parce que la décision sur chypre
népalais
la première qui pose de problèmes après
une longue période de fermeture les
agences bancaires ont réouvert leurs
guichets quelques heures par jour avec
toujours ces mêmes files d'attentes de
chypriotes inquiets pour leurs épargnes
des banques qui représentait il y a
quelques semaines encore le poumon
économique de l'île treize mille emplois
et des actifs équivalents à 8 fois le
pib du pays
le secteur bancaire avait su attirer les
capitaux étrangers grâce à des taux
d'imposition particulièrement bas mais
andreas comme la plupart de ses
compatriotes refuse qu'on parle de
chypre comme d'un paradis fiscal
vous savez on a des règles très sévères
sur le blanchiment d'argent ici et elles
sont appliquées ce sont des accusations
injustifiées
on n'autorise pas les transactions
d'argent sale non nous ne sommes pas une
économie casino
d'ailleurs les casinos il n'y en a pas à
chypre ils sont de l'autre côté côté
turc
pour lui la crise vient d'abord de la
grèce incapable de rembourser les prêts
que lui avait accordée chypre un effet
domino qui a sombré aujourd'hui l'avenir
professionnel d'andreas désormais le
banquier envisage de quitter son pays
seul moyen de conserver son confortable
train de vie je me tiens déjà prêts à
partir à l'étranger en ce moment j'en
vois des cv notamment dans les pays du
golfe
en europe aussi à bruxelles et à londres
son cas illustre le malaise de tout un
peuple impuissant devant cette crise
financière qui commence déjà à produire
ses effets dans l'économie locale à
nicosie la principale artère commerciale
voit ses magasins fermés les uns après
les autres et tout laisse à croire que
dans les prochaines années
les chypriotes devront se serrer la
ceinture alors voilà donc pour ce
reportage à chypre signé jeremy hartmann
nous sommes sur ce plateau avec robert
gaubert
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
européen vous êtes du groupe socialiste
vous êtes luxembourgeois on parlera
d'ailleurs du cas du luxembourg avec
vous dans quelques instants
d'abord une question sur chypre comment
est il possible selon vous qu on
découvre en tout cas que le grand public
découvre comme ça que au sein de l'union
européenne
il y avait depuis des années une place
financière offshore jeu
le grand public découvre peut-être mais
c'était quand même connu c
d'ailleurs un héritage eux
l'ancien empire britannique qui a cédé
sont au chaud un peu partout quand on
voit les vrais paradis fiscaux à travers
le monde
que ce soit en gros c'est bien pour les
bahamas les virgin à lens
et puis plus près jeu égal c'est à la
semaine tous les sas et les fatigues de
l'onf et laissez pas chaud ici pas
choquant quand même que déjà on est fait
rentrer dans l'union européenne dans la
zone euro une place financière au chaud
le fait que lapointe places financières
soient offshore n'est pas choquant en
soi si cette place financière applique
les règles européennes
elle est bon il faut jamais oublier que
dans l'union européenne ni à la libre
circulation des capitaux ou tous promis
à la libre circulation des marchandises
des services et des hommes
c'est un des grands principes fondateurs
de l'union européenne donc le fait de
placer son argent à chypre n'a rien de
répréhensible là où ça commence à
devenir un peu plus dangereux c'est que
ceux qui ont des comptes là bas oubli de
lezoux de les indiquer à l'office
national et le bien par mois y avait
surtout des russes c'est ça le fait
chier le fait quand même qui au sein de
l'union européenne
une place qui blanchissent de l'argent
alors en provenance d'europe mais
essentiellement en provenance de russie
ça ça vous choque pas écoutez je ne sais
pas s'ils ont fait du blanchiment
d'argent il existe des règles très
strictes
notre mois imposé par la gare fidèles
ocde
et qui sont appliqués un peu partout en
europe en tout cas dans mon pays mais je
ne sais pas comment les autres les
chypriotes ont traité tout cela
je constate simplement que maintenant
tout le monde tombe sur les pauvres
chypriotes qui ont essentiellement perdu
leur argent en grèce parce qu'ils
avaient signé des obligations d'état
grecques et lorsque nous européenne a
obligé tous les détenteurs d'obligations
grecques à subir un r4 donc être envoyée
en collatéral
chypre a perdu beaucoup d'argent et les
banques chypriotes se sont retrouvés
avec des trouées dans sas était si près
victime est une victime de cette c'était
prévisible
tout est prévisible surtout quand on
connaît la suite
c'est toujours plus facile d'expliquer
par la suite
et moi je constate par exemple quelqu'un
qui place son argent en france est un
investisseur il ya même des russes qui
ont placé de l'argent en france ils sont
des investisseurs et vivent entièrement
financé des clubs je suis folle en
grande bretagne sont des investisseurs
mais quand ils placent leur argent à
chypre sont des criminels
je vois que vous voulez en venir
on va parler d'un instant du luxembourg
il ya justement une question d'un député
chypriote convient d'entendre et il a
une question c'est même plutôt une
affirmation en ce qui concerne le
luxembourg regardez vous savez là aussi
on exagère les secteurs financière
chypriote pour vraiment dit c'était aux
environs de 8% du pib 7,9 pour cent au
moment que luxembourg par exemple c'est
quelque chose qu'on 20%
alors depuis le début de la crise
chypriote
le luxembourg est fortement critiquée
est ce que vous êtes dehors at war
mais le luxembourg effectivement une
place bancaire c'est pas un paradis
fiscal non luxembourg n'est pas un prix
auxquelles fahradi fiscale en europe
maxence effectivement il n'y a pas de
paradis fiscal les paradis fiscaux je
viens de les citer de leur était un
territoire britannique
même dans l'europe combien de ces jeux
c'est l'art hoffman gibraltar tout ça
c'est bettany et puis il ya les autres
avec son bourg tout un chacun paie
d'impôts que les banques paient l'impôt
est bon pétain d'impôt de 30% sur leurs
gains un français qui placent en nageant
à luxembourg se voit opérer une retenue
à la source de 35% sur les intérêts
qu'il a gagné alors héhéhé
sur ces 35 % la grande ajoutée et
transféré en france office alors serré
vous savez que l'un des éléments pour la
définition d'un paradis fiscal même s'il
ya une polémique sur qu'est-ce qu'un
paradis fiscal c'est l'opacité
pourquoi le luxembourg même si la
position est visiblement en train de
changer et il avec l'autriche l'un des
deux seuls pays d'europe qui refuse la
transmission automatique de données aux
autres pays européens
parce que nous avons toujours estimé
qu'une
contenu à la source était beaucoup plus
facile à faire et d'ailleurs la grande
ajouter des pays de l'union européenne
pour les résidents nationaux
on opère une retenue à la source en
france si vous touchez des intérêts sur
votre compte on opère une autre est à la
source c'est un système beaucoup plus
facile que cette transmission
mais tous azimuts même chose au débat
non parce que 6 1 6 1 et à demande à
luxembourg des informations cieux aura
difficilement
non non non non il fallait que chaque
année ce soir
chaque année il ya des centaines et des
centaines de commissions rogatoires
ils sont tous donnés par un juge
français et qui concernent des citoyens
français qui ont des pratiques
il faut faire une demande ce qui confère
une demande spécifique qui il faut le
dire est ce que monsieur cahuzac raconte
à luxembourg mais pour ce moment là les
autres thés judiciaire faut obliger les
banques luxembourgeoises vivriers tout
mais ce que nous avons toujours venus
empêcher c'est que le fisc puissent
faire une sorte pêche à l'aveuglé parce
que le script en jeu parce que le secret
bancaire est quand même également une
certaine protection
imaginez que le secret bancaire n'aurait
pas prévalu en suisse la deuxième guerre
mondiale
toutes les parents juifs ont été
confisqués par les nazis
est ce vraiment un politique on n'est
plus là aujourd'hui si on a quand même
pas mal de dictature encore à travers le
monde
et même en europe qui pourchasse alors
ils ont longuement parce que ça va être
le secret bancaire vous pouvez protéger
des dictateurs par exemple non nous ne
protégeons rien parce que l'argent sale
à luxembourg est pourchassé il existe un
rapport annuel qui vous dit que les
banques sont obligées à le sens bourg de
signaler tout mouvement de capital
suspects et cet argent là est saisi et
retourner volontairement à ce qu'ils
devraient
définir ses capitaux encore une fois
jusqu'à présent le gouvernement
luxembourgeois comme le gouvernement
autrichien comme gouverment ont fusé
quelques autres ont estimé que le secret
bancaire bien agencé était une
protection ou pour les humbles citoyens
parce que ça sera ma dernière question
est-ce que puisque le gouvernement
luxembourgeois a dit que les choses
étaient en train d'évoluer qu'il était
prêt à faire éventuellement des
concessions ça vous trouvez que c'est
une bonne chose ou où ça va tuer
l'industrie de votre pays non ça ne va
certainement pas tuer l'industrie notre
prix de toute façon la place financière
luxembourgeoise c'est devenu une passe
financière très international qui fait
un essentielle ment des investissements
ce qui explique terre pourquoi
effectivement le poids de cette
industrie est très important par rapport
au produit intérieur brut de mon pays
mais la situation est toute différente
de celle de chypre chypre avait une
place financière qui avait augmenté au
congo si au cours des années mais où
tous passionnés entre deux pays le
luxembourg par exemple est le plus grand
investisseur de l'europe en russie
ou en amérique du sud ou en asie non
c'est une situation totalement différent
et les ceux qui investissent sont des
sociétés qui ont pignon sur rue très
bien merci beaucoup à robert goebbels on
aura noté selon vous dont il n'existe
pas de paradis fiscal en europe merci en
tout cas d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est la fin de cette
émission on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine avec katia guidère pour une
nouvelle émission d'europe d'eau de
d'ici là bonne suite de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires